you
I should have said notes we don't
necessarily want you or anyone else can
go there and fun process rather we
control your brains we can Toronto fools
can make one is that really what
infectious pencil
there's a World Health report was
published end of the last century
predicting what the major diseases were
going to be affecting the world and
number three is major depression not in
terms of killing people but certainly on
their lifestyle and their morbidities or
the downstream consequences of being
depressed makes you more likely to get
diseases it's more likely to die from
other things in silence it's a it's a
major major health problem and then the
question is how do you actually go about
improving that situation and what
approaches do you have
so the way in which we try to understand
how brains produce illness how brains
produce behavior is at the level of the
circuits within them and whereas in the
past people have ideas about bad thing
happening due to a Sigmund Freud type
analysis of brain function would be do
some experience you had and more
recently we've been using genetic
approaches understand what might
predispose you to an illness what we're
trying now to do is say that these
problems arise from brain activity so
let me take an example we've done some
genetic work where we think that a set
of genes involved in acting
depolarization is involved in emotion
so it's not clear why something as basic
as actual would be involved in the brain
in emotional regulation so we actually
thought well could we find it in flies
so this is so basic would you find it in
a fly brain do find it in the fly brain
fly has this particular gene has this
particular enzyme so then we just have
to test her whether the fly gets a bit
upset if we manipulate that part of its
cellular structure we can do that in
flies was we couldn't do that in humans
and it's very difficult to do it in in
mammals but cheap and easy relatively to
do it in flight so we do that
manipulation and lo and behold we find
an expected change so you'll see in a
moment to flies in one fly we've
genetically engineered the neurons that
make it fly so that when we turn a laser
light on the fly will far away while its
mate who does not have light responsive
neurons will stay behind so watch for
the flash of light so this works well in
flies where the light can get into the
brain but not so well in mammals because
we have a skull so there you moved from
thinking about a problem on a rather
global scale have an insight into
whether it's a structural or functional
process that might be conserved and then
test the hypothesis directly in a in a
model organism so you need those
resources to answer these questions
we're going to have you grab the chairs
move yourselves close enough to the
board to really be part of the
conversation no wanna go there can be no
one who doesn't have a certain degree of
discomfort most of the people here are
supportive of all advances in technology
or not you know trying to stop learning
but you must confront this on a daily or
at least monthly basis I'll be one of
these all right I'll problem is the
brains don't want to be controlled so we
have to overcome this barrier the brains
hand
they can't be sorry we definitely want
to control brains what I've given you is
a totally overblown description of
what's possible the moment you got that
so at the moment all we can do is make a
mouse run around and that's about as
best to get those little bit better we
can make an go to sleep so you can put a
light into a part of the brain and then
it'll fall asleep and it'll it'll wake
up but in order to do anything more
sophisticated than that I mean it's just
we're at the very very beginning on that
initial problem and then I got the
problem that the biology is horrendously
complicated we only know fractional
what's going on in brains we don't
really know how they work they don't
know how they've produced feelings
without knowing that information how
come how can I understand what's going
wrong in somebody's brain so put those
things together and you have one of
those challenging problems and biology
you
Oh